- What book are you
reading right now, man?
What are you on?
- I don't read books.
- Word?
- Word.
- Crazy.
- That's not how I learn.
- [Man] Just writes them.
- Just writes them?
(chuckles)
Lit.
- [Gary] I, you know--
- I don't read books, I write 'em.
- [Gary] Based on my thesis that
hip hop rules the world,
it's probably a 50 billion
dollar company if you--
- What's your thesis?
- Hip hop rules the world.
- Fucking with you bro.
- [Man] Shit.
(imitates phone ringing)
♪ Movin' it quick ♪
♪ Tryna get rich and I'm
dodgin' these sticks ♪
♪ Got head in the Uber,
then call me a Lyft ♪
♪ She pissed but it is
what it is what it is ♪
♪ Girl, I'm stuck up in my ways, yeah ♪
♪ Get the fuck outta my face ♪
- What can we help you guys with?
- Honestly, just wanted to come say hello.
- I'm glad.
- Just wanted to say
what's up man.
- Yeah, man, say word up.
Same, thank you for everything.
- [Gary] So proud of you.
- Thanks for everything.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Thank you for all the wisdom.
It's lit, it's always appreciated.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Mm-hmm.
- Thank you. What are you working on?
- We're finishing that, well actually,
the album's fuckin' done.
The debut album's done.
It comes out March 27th.
- Let's go.
- Whoo, so excited about that.
- I don't know when you guys are like--
Put this out or anything.
But it's just that March
27 the album comes out.
We have like, it's like you, how you work
is just a piece of concept
for every single video.
I mean every single song, you
got 15 songs on the album.
There's a music video for that, there is--
- Let's make sure ONE37 and PureWow,
give some awareness.
Then we do, like a deep feature on PureWow
because that's a demo that I think
could really play for her like that
slightly older woman
like just broadens her.
Talk to Mary Kate--
- [Jessie] That's the demographic
that you guys have online like (murmurs)
- Yeah, so ONE37pm is the thing
that we went into alpha last.
So the way we did it is I bought a company
three years ago called PureWow,
which is kinda like 29
to 46 year old women.
Like literally like that,
like a little bit older
for digital publishers like Refinery29,
all those other things a little younger.
Bought that and the plan was to build
a men's compliment that's
viewed much younger,
15 to 35 male and that's what ONE37pm is.
Year one, alpha, not even beta.
Just like get it out,
watch, build a culture,
let them sit with me.
This is year two beta
so that's why his podcast,
more content from him.
- [Jessie] Oh right, yeah, congrats.
- [Man] Congrats man.
- [Jessie] Congrats.
- You're starting to see more stuff.
You're gonna see a lot
more starting April, May.
I promise I'm sure you'll
ping me in September
be like, Yo, you told me and here it is,
'cause you're just gonna
see ONE37 so much more
in TikTok and Instagram.
You're just gonna see it more.
And then next year is gonna be like,
okay, like we're the fucking culture.
People are gonna be like
begging to be featured
or collab with ONE37, that's the plan.
- That's sick man.
- [Man] I mean everybody's already
fucking with you anyways so I mean--
- Yeah, it's just putting the
infrastructure around that.
That's exactly, it's scaling
what I am as a human,
that scale as a publisher,
because you guys know me.
It's about I wanna be valued.
- I actually brought a
lot of value when you,
the TikTok stuff you were talking about
and her name is escaping me
right now and she doesn't even--
Her whole headline: I don't
get it either, What's--
- [Gary] Charlie?
- Charlie, charlie.
Yeah, and I looked into her and
that's when I started to see
like Oh, this is serious.
- Oh, no, no, no, Tiktok's more important
for Jessie than Instagram.
- Totally and we got
on that the other day.
- Yeah we got on (murmurs)
- More important than Instagram.
- Can you, I have a question actually
now that we're here about TikTok.
TikTok is definitely, in my opinion,
a game of like that's quantity
like you put out four or five videos--
- Everybody's got Instagram wrong.
People got fancy with their Instagram
and think it's like their
fuckin' like art gallery.
Like anybody gives a fuck.
People got fancy and insecure.
- But specifically for
TikTok, let's say, first--
- TikTok, Twitter, YouTube,
it's content at scale.
If she sat and said Denver, what's good?
And did that for every city,
and put that in front of
whatever she said next,
and then you ran ads against that,
she'd be ten times bigger as an artist.
'Cause you created context.
Who fucks with her?
People that associate with her.
The more she sings about them,
as she evolves as a human,
when she's 41,
whatever she's talking about,
somebody who's going through
that is gonna understand that.
It's about connection points.
People fuck with me
because I'm a Jets fan.
People fuck with me because
I'm an entrepreneur.
People fuck with me 'cause I like music.
People fuck with me
because I like, Got it?
Show 'em everything
you're willing to share.
On the flip side, don't
share my personal life.
Everybody basically tries
to win on social media
by showing their relationships,
their kids, and their pets.
I'm the reverse, I'm
just tryna bring value.
I'm the most private public
person on earth, right?
- [Jessie] Which is lovely.
- Which is, you know what,
and I don't judge people
that share every single thing
about their relationship
and family 'cause that's
what they're about.
That's fine, I'm just
saying be you, fully you.
And show them other things.
I'm sure when you were here last time,
and I knew you were here
playing video games,
like another person was like
"Whoa, she fucks with video games?,
now I fuck with her music."
Show 'em everything you
got as often as possible
across every platform and
when a new platform pops
and it's under priced, the land grab,
that's when it matters.
(man mumbles)
- That's organic.
- 'Cause it's not even
about the platform with you.
It's just about putting the
content on the platform.
- [Gary] And then the context
cause I know on LinkedIn--
- Exactly, which is what we
were just talking about that--
- She should be pounding a minimum a day
of like my secret message for TikTok
And she's talking to
13 to 16 year old girls
about her framework about
when she was 13 to 16,
what she's observing about 13 to 16,
what she thinks about 13 to 16,
a story when she was 13 'cause
that's who's fucking there.
She can be the biggest
star on TikTok in a year
if she fuckin' speaks
and spits to those girls.
I'm sure you've got plenty funny stories
when you were 14.
- Oh, yup.
(mumbles)
- They wanna know what you were thinking,
or what this 14 year old said
to you in a meet and greet
or how you see it or the
DM you read the other day.
Context, context and then content at scale
around that context and that's what I
am showing the world and
everybody who follows me
the most carefully and
actually does it wins,
and everybody who doesn't
judges me without context.
- Well, we came out of
that meeting with you
like a year ago, you flash
back to like one year ago.
- [Gary] You know how we do it.
- Exactly, exactly.
- [Gary] You're producing now.
- Yeah, and literally like we came
and then it was like a
song a week, a song a week,
and then the EP and then--
- [Gary] A collab, a collab.
- Yeah, and we did it in collaboration--
- [Gary] And what happened?
- Yeah, and now we're going again,
like doing that again, and
just like this is like a...
- I'm just waiting for you to name drop me
in one of your songs,
that's what I'm waiting for.
(chuckles)
- Lit, in the adlib, Gary.
- [Gary] Whatever you want.
- That's dope.
(mumbles)
- Actually, so my advice right now
on the PureWow thing, like in ONE37,
even though its users are more male,
like in the culture, you're winnin'.
That's why I want, that's
why I want PureWow.
I want a 39 year old mom in Kansas
to read a bio, a profile on you
and be like who's that, Google, listen.
That's why it's gonna work, got it?
Context, different places.
That's why collabs are so amazing.
Both artists get to cross over fan bases.
- The Eminem collab got a lot too.
That shit was nuts.
- [Gary] I watched.
- The Eminem one.
- [Man] Oh yeah yeah?
- That was like a prime example of that.
- [Man] Yeah yeah, absolutely.
- All of them, obviously
he's at such scale.
That was the biggest cost,
I mean we fuckin' were
dancing here when we saw that.
Dancing, our tech storm exploded
the second the first
person who saw it saw it.
- [Jessie] That's crazy man.
- We cheer for you heavy.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Gary] For real, for real.
- What book are you reading right now man?
What are you on?
- I don't read books.
- Word?
- [Gary] Word.
- Crazy.
- That's not how I learn.
- [Man] Just writes them.
- He just writes them? (laughs)
Lit, I don't read books, I write 'em.
- You know how I learn, I read
comments, and I read DM's.
This is why I so relate Boyd,
the way that Boyd's got
his ear into the streets
and hip hop and La Trappe
and shit like that.
I have my ear to the
streets on a human level.
That's why I know shit to poke at
'cause people write it to
me and I read, and I watch.
When you were on the MTV
Awards thing and did you thing,
I read every single tweet,
all of them, all of them.
I didn't even watch your performance.
It was the background as it was happening.
You were on and I was reading the tweets
in real time about you.
- [Man] Crazy.
- I don't consume that thing, I consume
the people consuming the thing.
- [Jessie] The reaction.
- That's how I always know shit, got it?
- [Boyd] Making the value of
putting out so many content.
- Correct, I put out content to learn.
I put out a post on Instagram this morning
that I know isn't really
made for Instagram
about how you should run
commercials on Hulu and Amazon
but I need to read the comments
to understand how they understood it.
I'm in fuckin' constant
motion of information.
I'm always talking because
I'm always listening.
- That sentence is lit.
(chuckles)
- Take it, use it, and then reference.
- And then shout out Gary
Vee in the song, lit.
Yeah man.
- [Boyd] Yeah she's killin'
the community texting too.
- That makes me so fuckin' happy.
- [Jessie] Yeah, we've
been on that like crazy.
- To me that's as big as it gets.
- [Man] We're gonna be on the road.
Jessie's doing about 80
to 85 shows in 19 weeks
so we're doing, she's
just doing headline tour
in North America and
Europe going through--
- Listen to me, listen to me really good.
I apologize for interrupting.
A lotta TikTok, like you.
Let them do their thing
but you, at least one.
It won't do as well in TikTok views
like you to the face,
no editing, no whatever,
no really workin' it,
but it's gonna fuckin'...
(chest pounds)
Everybody loses 'cause you're tryna hack,
get more followers, get more likes,
so then they go into a
box, they can't do shit.
The game is to actually connect
with an actual community.
And when you know who's listening,
then all of a sudden,
you're going in between
80 fucking five shows and you're tired,
and you make a video
all fucked up, sweaty,
finished, and you're like, listen,
two minutes ago, I was fucking tired,
and being like, fuck this shit,
I'm doing too much,
and then three seconds ago,
and this is why I'm making this video,
I said 14 year old me would
rip both her arms and legs off
to be doing this, got it?
You understand where I'm going?
- Yeah man.
- You see where I'm going?
That.
That's why I sit where I sit.
- Referencing back,
I'm gonna go downstairs and do a TikTok.
- Knowing the audience, knowing
what they're going through,
you, I don't know what a
14 year old went through
as well as you do 'cause you are one.
I know better than most 44 year old dudes
'cause I consume.
That's why I relate to them
when it makes no sense
for me to relate to them.
But that's just 'cause I have natured
emotional skills talents.
You are one, you were one.
You could connect
deeper, better, stronger.
If you're not putting
out three TikTok's a day,
for real, you're making a humongous
fundamental mistake for your career.
It's a music based platform.
The fuck are we talking about here.
This isn't Instagram or Twitter.
It's a music based platform.
It's the foundational
element of the platform.
I'm a 44 year old white dude
with 3 million followers on it.
The fuck are you guys doing, let's go.
You understand, let's go.
(mumbles)
You know what I mean?
- [Woman] Sorry.
- Yeah, man.
Hello, how you doin'?
- [Woman] How are you?
- That's what's up.
Thanks for the video the other day.
Great to see you man.
- [Jessie] How you doin' man, wassup?
- Thank you, good, how are you?
- Real good, wassup?
- [Man] Nice to see you again.
I want you to meet Murs real fast.
(mumbles)
- Have you guys never met?
- Jessie, how you doin'?
- Murs, how you doin'?
- Oh my god, you guys sit.
You guys have to know each
other, this is amazing.
Good job Boyd.
You two absolutely need
to know each other.
Like I know you both pretty damn well,
like obviously, know it
hasn't been enough time,
but I know you, like you two
really need to know each other.
- [Jessie] Oh, man. Where you from?
- I'm from LA.
- Okay, lit. Dope.
- Where are you from?
- Toronto.
- Toronto, okay.
- Yes sir.
- I just did a show at the Drake.
- Oh, lit, yo, one of my
earliest shows was at the Drake.
- I like it, it's nice.
I didn't stay there but--
- It's cool, it's nice.
- Yeah, they have convenient food and--
- Summertime? Did you go
in the summer or just now?
- No, it was cold, it was cold as shit.
- Boy, God bless you
and you liked it anyway?
- Yeah, I went to see
Come as You, Come Away,
come what is it?
Come Away with Me, the
new Broadway musical,
I'm into musicals, it was dope.
- [Gary] You enjoyed it?
- Yeah, I went to OVO store.
I did the whole tourist thing
and I met with my boy Shad.
I don't know if you know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Shad Kabango?
- Yeah
- Hip hop revolution?
- Yeah, yeah.
We like kicked it, had some drinks
with him and Skratch Bastid.
- Skratch Bastid's lit man.
- So like, you know, I've
been like doin underground--
- I'm telling you, I'm so
happy this is happening.
I might just--
- [Murs] But do you rap, do you sing?
- I sing and I write.
- Oh, you write?
- Yeah, I rap too but fuck,
I'm more of a singer than him.
- Stop it, you got bars.
- Few from Toronto can rap, man.
That's why Shad was like,
everybody's doin' somethin' else.
- They can't rap but they
can play video games.
Fuck you Toronto.
- Wow, oh my god.
(laughing)
(mumbles)
I do not endorse this shit.
- At the very least we can
play basketball in Toronto.
- They got a year for that.
- We in 12 with this court baby.
- You guys got three straight
and the only reason you're winning
is maybe RJ Barrett, I'm sorry.
- I'm so pumped we won three games.
We're in the number
one pick race all time.
(mumbles)
- [Murs] Oh man, is this Knicks talk?
- This is a little Knicks,
What they're referring to is I own...
So the Call of Duty league just started
and I own, I'm the minority
owner of the Minnesota team.
And we have these two great rivalries:
Chicago 'cause my guy
Hector, who's the OG guy,
he's like part owner, like
runs the Chicago team,
and in football, the Bears
and the Vikings are rivals,
so we got this good little jam going.
But then there's this
Jersey kid that plays
who's on the Toronto team.
- Wait, how did he get to
Toronto if he's form Jersey?
- He's on, the same way Kawhi's
not from fucking Toronto.
- [Murs] Okay so you could do that?
You could do that in e-sports?
- You could do that in every sport.
So the Toronto team's
got a really good team
and they put something else on Twitter
like they're the real north.
And I don't know if you know,
but the latitude, longitude shit,
but Minnesota's higher than Toronto.
And so I'm just playing with them,
so I did like, a funny, I think,
When I compete, I'm a wrestler.
And I'm talking shit, I'm
gonna fucking get you, Toronto.
(mumbles)
But then like, I guess the clip
went on social and out of context,
they were like Yo, you don't like Toronto,
and there's a message board, I don't--
- Yeah, we pulled up today. We pulled--
(mumbles)
- How much time do you guys got?
We got 15 minutes, good
we're gonna talk about
this right now.
- Aboot?
- [Jessie] Aboot, oh my god.
- And then it's double crazy because,
I'm gonna have Boyd, I'm
gonna have D Rock find this,
I've actually publicly said this,
Toronto's the only city in my life
that I ever considered
living in besides New York.
That's how much I like being there.
It feels New York-y to me.
It's obviously much
smaller but it's feels it.
I fucking loved it so I got sad
when they were telling me,
I'm like no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
in e-sports, not in real life.
- [Man] We're just fuckin' with you man.
- I know.
- Yeah, you bustin' balls.
- [Gary] Fuckin' love Toronto.
- Fuckin' bustin' balls.
- Oh man.
- I don't need Killy coming in here
and punching me in the face.
- [Jessie] That's hilarious.
- [Murs] Killy, that
sounds like a bad person
to be pissed at you.
- [Jessie] Killy, he's actually nice.
- He's a sweet guy.
- [Murs] But he's got Killy in his name?
- Yeah, who cares man.
Just trying to make it nice.
- Nice kid.
- Your toys are nice man.
- [Gary] Thank you bro.
- I'm always like watching
what you're saying.
I'm never like observing the--
- Well, I'm humbled by
both those statements.
- [Murs] The monkey, I might
need to borrow that man.
- Were you like a big
wrestling fan, were you like--
- [Gary] Yes.
- Like going into the background stuff
like all the politics and the
locker room kind of stuff?
- [Gary] Yeah, I loved wrestling.
- Me too--
- [Gary] I loved it, like how old are you?
- I'm 36.
- So you got the whole like NWO--
- [Man] No, 'cause my
cousin's seven years old
and he's so much, I don't like--
- Yeah, yeah, Dude,
Macho Man Randy Savage,
you know it's funny, obviously,
with Kobe's passing,
like I've actually made a
huge decision in my life,
that I know, so the way I,
it's actually a lot of my advice
is the same game which is I just do good
and I do good work and I execute
and then the things I want
actually then come to me.
But I think it manifested
in an over exaggeration version of that.
I really really regret,
the amount of times
mutual friends were like
you and Kobe must be best friends
'cause of just mindset, framework,
competition, whatever it is,
and I would always be like,
no we haven't even met.
Always in the back of my mind I'd be like
he'll be hitting me up any moment, right?
And I really regret
it, I really regret it.
And I really challenge
myself to say you know what,
even thought it has 90%
do good to the end world,
and it will come to you, I'd be lying
if I didn't say that 10% ego in it.
And when Kobe passed the other day,
I decided to eliminate the 10%.
And when I admire somebody
who I like what they're doing,
I'm just gonna give them love.
And I do that for people
that are comin' up, all day
but not the ones that are at the top
and I'm gonna start.
- Do you wait for them to come to you?
- 100%, that's what happened,
and they all do, and they all will
but I have to change because I regret
not meeting Kobe and having that dinner,
and that's the way it is and
the reason I brought that up
is besides that, which is more micro,
literally the single person
that I wish I got to meet
before they died was Randy
"The Macho Man" Savage.
Loved him, he was like,
I would argue that if
you carefully break down
how I give key notes,
it is a mix between Randy
"The Macho Man" Savage,
Chris Rock and Eddie Murphy,
and little bit of like
KRS-One storytelling stuff.
Like if you really look,
and then I was like man,
that's how it happens, right?
You are influenced even
when you don't know
you're being influenced.
When I'm promoting an event,
it's literally like March 17th
in the Hartford Civic
Center, I'm coming for the,
It's basically it,
literally a wresting promo.
- It's a promo, it's a
wrestling promo for sure.
- 100%
- Like the 1980's promo with
the badger on the shirt.
- And Jess, back to
what I was telling you,
I didn't even know it
until I started reading it
when people are like, yo that
looks like a wrestling promo.
- [Jessie] Reading through
the comments, yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause you don't
know, you're in your shit.
We don't know, we can't see it.
So by reading and not thinking,
And by the way, it's also when
people say shit about you,
people go troll, hater,
mmhmm, it's a human.
Nine out of 10 times it is somebody
who is insecure and sad about themselves
trying to manifest and tear you down.
- [Jessie] Yeah, but it
could be constructive.
- But one out of 10
times, it's constructive
and you have to be empathetic
so you gotta read 'em all.
- [Murs] You read all the comments?
- I read all of the
comments, that's all I do.
No time I'm thinking about the context
like everybody else who
fucking debates their angles
and coloring and lighting
and fucking everything else--
- [Murs] Fuck that.
- So they project to
the world who they are.
No, I am who I am, go, and
then read all the comments.
- And get better.
- Everybody's PR'ing and
positioning and not listening
and I'm just listening and living.
That's the difference,
that's what, that's it.
(upbeat music)